after more than a week flying around U.S
airspace the Chinese spy balloon or at
least one of them has finally been shot
down the international incident has
provoked all sorts of questions what
were the Chinese looking for why did the
U.S government let it get halfway across
the country before acknowledging that
the Chinese spy balloon even existed why
did it take so long for Biden to shoot
the damn thing down all fine questions
we should get the answers
but there are more important questions
that we should get answers to first
because Despite All The Sensational
headlines the balloon is not that big a
story
what is the story what is the news from
the Chinese spy balloon
that China is spying on the United
States
we already know that
every powerful country on earth is
constantly spying on every other
powerful country and this is especially
true of the US and China the global
hegemon and now the rising second power
the balloon is the least of it whatever
intelligence China picked up from the
balloon I promise you they have picked
up 10 times 100 times more
more than 100 times more information
from their satellites over our heads and
their Telecom systems that they have in
the U.S and the technology that they
manufacture for us almost exclusively
the supply chain they control entirely
and the social media spy app Tick Tock
that we all willingly download to our
phones through which we give the Chinese
access to our data our voices our
locations our faces
what's the story here Biden is
incompetent and corrupt and dominated by
the Chinese
yeah we already knew that
it's all troubling I'm not denying it
I'm not excusing anything
but my only questions are one
why are we all talking about this stupid
balloon that doesn't reveal anything new
about our political order and two
what are we conveniently for our rulers
not discussing while everybody is
distracted by the shiny object floating
in the sky I'm Michael knowlesis the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment Friday is from Robert copter who
says pretty harsh comparing Tom Brady
playing a few more months of football to
causing the downfall of a kingdom listen
some people thought that my comparison
between Tom Brady and Hezekiah king of
Judah was harsh and I think it was harsh
but it was fair okay that's the way it
goes that's the way it goes you don't
want to live a life that is unbalanced
okay and and when you want to restore
balance to your own body
you need to check out balance of nature
right now go to balanceofnature.com use
promo code Knowles you know I love
balance of nature can be tough to think
okay did I get all my right fruits and
veggies and this vitamin and that no
people don't pay attention to that okay
balance of nature fruits and veggies
that's the best way to make sure that
you are getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day their
products are 100 Whole Food balance of
nature uses a cold vacuum process that
preserves the natural phytonutrients in
whole fruits and vegetables and
encapsulates them for easy consumption
balance of nature sent a bunch of their
products down to our office for our team
to try and these animals these hyenas
right when I go I say okay maybe I'll
get a couple more bags of that they're
gone these animals just take them all
for themselves my my colleagues over
here well when you are disciplined
enough to take care of your health you
reap all kinds of benefits that's why
everyone wants to take them more energy
less fatigue better focus consuming the
right balance of fruits and veggies
every day is an important First Step go
to balanceofnature.com promo code
Knowles for 35 off your first order as a
preferred customer plus a free fiber and
spice that's balanceofnature.com promo
code nulls for 35 off your first
preferred order I'm immediately going to
violate my own advice and talk about
this balloon but only briefly I'm going
to talk about the balloon very briefly
because everyone's talking about it but
then I want to move on to stories that I
think really matter because I think that
the stories we're not talking about
while we're all distracted by a literal
balloon the only way it could have been
more on the nose is if is if it were a
Chinese spy butterfly we're all there
and we say hey man you guys hear that
Pfizer executive who just admitted that
Pfizer is planning to conduct gain of
function research or directed Evolution
research to beef up the viruses and
actually he also did Jerry admitted that
the vaccines it would seem affect
women's fertility oh look a butterfly
oh look a balloon what were we talking
about probably wasn't that important
right uh however I will run through it
very very quickly
the Chinese spyballoon was first
identified over Billings Montana that
was the first balloon then there was a
second balloon that was observed over
Canada there might be a third balloon in
Latin America there may be another
balloon in the United States the
Department of Defense revealed on Friday
that the Spy balloon
is not just a balloon in the sense that
you don't just kind of Let It Go
chairman she lets it go over the Pacific
we see where it lands the balloon is
apparently maneuverable
so it would appear to be controlled
remotely or by artificial intelligence
DOD observed it changing direction at 60
000 feet in the air and so that the
first call was why aren't we shooting
this thing down here's what Joe Biden
had to say
I ordered the Pentagon to shoot it down
on Wednesday as soon as possible they
decided without doing damage to anyone
on on the ground
they decided that the best time to do
that was they got over water outside
within our within 12 mile limit
it successfully took it down and I want
to complement our aviators who did it
and we'll have more to report on this uh
a little later thank you I told him to
shoot it down and they didn't want to
shoot it down right away when I told
them on Wednesday but they eventually
they did okay why didn't they want to
shoot it down right away by the way the
dod knew about this days but there's
almost a week or I'm sorry more than a
week
uh from the time that the
drone balloon plane thing entered U.S
airspace to the time we shot it down
then Biden says oh yeah I told him to
shoot it down on Wednesday but we were
afraid it could harm civilians on the
ground that was that was the storyline
at least they shoot the thing down
doesn't seem very credible to me though
according to the Pentagon it was
strongly recommended by chairman of the
Joint Chiefs General milley who had just
taken a break from his uh White
Privilege struggle session and was he
left the transgender bathroom at the
Pentagon and came out and he I'm I I'm
just assuming this is what happened but
then he urged the commander of northcom
not to take kinetic action due to the
risk of Safety and Security of the
people on the ground from the possible
debris field in terms of size I'm not
able to get into specifics other than to
say it's big enough that in reviewing
our approach we do recognize any
potential debris field would be
significant and potentially cause
civilian injuries or deaths or
significant property damage I don't
believe that I don't think that is true
I think that the U.S has very Advanced
military capabilities and this is a very
vast country that is largely uninhabited
and the idea that one of our aviators
can't capture or completely destroy a
Chinese spy balloon without killing
civilians is just patently absurd
and clearly some cya they didn't want to
have to answer for why they did not
shoot this thing down then Bloomberg
reported U.S officials were well aware
that the balloon was in U.S airspace as
early as January 28th and then it was
over Idaho on Tuesday and they didn't
want to tell the public why didn't they
want to tell the public because
secretary of state blinken is supposed
to go to China
now this week and and that trip is now
off okay so then then
the question is why why did it all take
so long
why do we know about it why did it all
all take so long
it it took so long according to the
administration because this happens all
the time
that's seriously their argument the
argument is oh we get these spy plans
all the time
and they happened under Trump they
happened a lot more under Trump than
they happened under under Biden that
that was the Biden administration's line
and Marco Rubio seemed to back it up
Rubio said this is not the first time
that this has happened it's not the
first time by the way I mean we've seen
these before I just think yesterday the
acknowledgment of it is because they
knew people were going to be seeing it
and and there were going to be reports
about it and you couldn't hide it and
look there's Those sensors and those
things that they're Gathering but they
can also get that information from
satellite they can get that information
from all of the Huawei equipment and
routers that are still installed across
the United States I mean there's a
million ways they can gather this
information that they want and they are
doing it their Espionage levels have
grown as much as anything else this is
just one more method that they use to
collect Intelligence on us and so we
have to be cognizant of it and protect
ourselves against it so the first part
is this is not the first time this has
happened seems to affirm what the Biden
admin is saying which is that we had all
sorts of Chinese spy balloons under
Trump except
that after the Biden Administration said
that and after Rubio said that the
former Director of National Intelligence
John Radcliffe came out and said no
there were no Chinese spy balloons under
Trump stop trying to distract from
Biden's failures this is not a trump
thing this is not a permanent problem
thing this is on Joe Biden
Department of Defense is claiming a
three
balloons
Chinese spy balloons that entered the
United space airspace during the Trump
Administration and that they were not
shot down and they were not disclosed
can you please tell us the truth and if
that's true well it's not true I can I
can refute it former Secretary of
Defense uh Mark esper refuted it
yesterday second former Secretary of
State and CIA director Mike Pompeo has
refuted it but Maria the American people
can refute it for themselves
um uh do you remember during the Trump
Administration when photographers on the
ground and commercial airline pilots
were talking about a spy balloon over
the United States that people could look
up and see even with the with the naked
eye and the media that hated Donald
Trump wasn't reporting I don't remember
that either because it didn't happen so
Ratcliffe former Director of National
Intelligence says didn't happen he
refers here to Mike Pompeo former CIA
director secretary of state says didn't
happen Mark esper former Secretary of
Defense says it didn't happen in
addition to that Rick Grinnell former
acting dni says it didn't happen Robert
O'Brien former National Security adviser
says it didn't happen and then here's to
me the most convincing one
John Bolton another former National
Security adviser
says it didn't happen and John Bolton
doesn't like Donald Trump John Bolton
left the Trump Administration with a
kind of a nasty relationship with Trump
he wrote a book about how he disagreed
with Trump on all sorts of things and so
Bolton has a lot of credibility here but
these guys have no incentive
to carry water for Trump or hide
something that happened under Trump I
suspect
that it's all kind of a moot point
in that yes the Biden Administration is
trying to deflect and trying to pretend
that that this specific incident
happened a lot under Trump and so it's
not a big deal and pay no attention
but the issue that Rubio is talking
about and that others are talking about
the fact that China regularly spies on
us all the time they're doing it right
now with our phones if if you have Tick
Tock certainly and plenty of other ways
too they are spying on the United States
so who cares who cares what's
what's the point
why are we talking about this now and I
think we're largely talking about this
now because
one people saw it with their own eyes
and so the the administration did have
its hand forced
but also I strongly suspect that the
reason that there is a big push to talk
about this now is because it it's
Sensational but it doesn't really
involve any new information and actually
the stories that have been in the news
recently have genuinely been scandalous
have been very bad for our ruling Elite
and so much better to distract everybody
with a balloon
now when you want to protect your data
seems pretty important whenever it's
spying on us you got to check out
expressvpn right now go to
expressvpn.com
Knowles companies are not just selling
products anymore they're selling you
tech companies enrich themselves by
taking your personal data they grab your
web history your email metadata and
video searches to create a detailed
profile on you then they sell that off
to the highest bidder when you go online
without a VPN internet service providers
can see every single website you visit
they can legally sell this information
without your consent to ad companies and
Tech Giants who then use it to Target
you to keep my data private I have for a
very very long time now used expressvpn
I love expressvpn because it's super
easy you know I'm something of a Luddite
very easy you just download it to your
laptop your tablet your phone one click
of a button you are protected you can
mask your IP address with expressvpn
reroutes your connection through an
encrypted server that makes it more
difficult for third parties to find you
right now if like me you believe that
your data or your business secure
yourself with the number one rated VPN
on the market expressvpn.com nulls get
three extra months for free
expresvpn.com
expressvpn.com Knowles to learn more
you know what I want to talk about
instead of that spy balloon
I want to talk about how projects vary
to us had more information than they
released in that in that first expose on
the Pfizer executive I want to talk
about how they have clips of the Pfizer
executive
explaining how the vax likely affects
women's menstrual cycles
about their menstrual cycle so you will
have to investigate that down the line
yeah
that is a little concerning the action
shouldn't be interfering with that so we
don't really it shouldn't it shouldn't
but is it there's something happening
but we don't know
well I mean you're a urologist so you
must understand like what's going on
with it right like well that's why I
just said that it's weird I hope we
don't find out that like the somehow
this mRNA like even losing the body and
then they like they pass because what it
has to be affecting public hormonals
they impact Minister Cycles yeah or like
the entire next Generations could you
imagine the Scandal oh my God I take
Pfizer off my resume
can you imagine can you because we were
all told initially that there's no way
that the vaccines possibly could affect
women's menstrual cycles in fact you had
Public Health officials go on television
on major television shows and say it was
scientifically medically impossible for
the vaccines to affect women's menstrual
cycles and then
a year two years later the scientists
start to slowly admit okay it can have
an effect on women's menstrual cycles
yeah okay sure it but it's not a big
deal it goes right back to normal forget
about this move along
and then you get this guy the Pfizer
executive saying
Dan something's up
and the the Honeypot undercover
journalist says
are you saying that it's affecting
women's menstrual cycles and the Pfizer
exec says well it's not supposed to
says but is it
and what is the visor exactly he says
what we've all been saying he says well
something's going on
yeah obviously something's going on I I
love that that
shift even in in the speech of the
Pfizer executive himself where he says
well it's not supposed to be happening
all of our genius scientists said it's
not supposed to be happening
but like something's up man I I don't
know I hope this isn't isn't what it
looks like I'm gonna have to take Pfizer
off my resume
which he very well might have to do soon
because of this expose
I'm not even beating up on Jordan Walker
or the Pfizer guy I'm I'm frankly not
even beating up on Pfizer so much as I'm
beating up on the entire modern
understanding of science
the modern understanding of science is
that for all of human history people
have been big stupid superstitious
idiots and they were essentially doing
rain dances and having shamanistic
rituals by witch doctors and none of
that actually had a medical effect in
the world but now we've got serious
scientists guys like Dr fauci and they
wear white lab coats and they have
stethoscopes on and they have fancy
degrees from Harvard and Princeton and
and Johns Hopkins and you can see it
there it's and they they have Spectacles
on and really serious affect and they
tell you I am the science I represent
the science and so you can't argue with
me I'm not political I'm just the
science and therefore they're right
about everything and it turns out
that those modern medical scientists
are not all that different from the old
witch doctor shamans dancing around
doing the rain the rain dance
the way that this Pfizer executive
clearly it had a couple drinks the way
that this Pfizer guy is talking about
the vaccine is the way that all of us
are talking about the vaccine which is
huh I it's doing a thing that I thought
it wasn't supposed to do wait you said
it was going to completely stop people
from Catching the virus but that
obviously wasn't true and you said it
was going to be totally safe and you
said it was going to be really effective
and none of that stuff turned out to be
true and
what usually when the Pfizer exacts when
the Dr fauci is when the public health
people know that they're on TV they keep
a totally straight face and they'll
they'll just say well no I what are you
talking about I never said it was going
to stop you from getting the virus no
well I don't know what you don't you
just don't understand the science and
you but privately their reactions are
exactly the same
as all of our reactions friend of mine
from college went to Harvard Medical
School ended up getting all sorts of
extra degrees brilliant brilliant guy
and I a comment that he made has really
stuck with me over the years where we
asked him hey you know how's medical
school and and all this other extra
research and scholarship that you're
doing on top of the Practical medical
training and he said the more I study
medicine
the more I am convinced that we still
don't know anything about medicine we
don't know why medicines work a lot of
the time we are throwing spaghetti at
the wall we are not so different
from the people doing rain dances
the difference is the pride
the difference is that back then at
least they didn't pretend to have every
single answer to everything in the world
it was a little more trial and error
today in in modern medicine we actually
are forced to believe
at contradictory statements from what
the scientists told us the day before
wear the masks you have to wear the
masks okay that's the science that's
okay if you dare question that you're a
dumb idiot don't wear the masks The
Masks don't work well that's the science
and I Know It contradicts what he said
yesterday but okay fine
you know what I want to talk about
instead of the balloon I want to talk
about
I want to talk about the masks I want to
talk about how a gold standard review of
mask science
shows that the masks are not quite as
effective
as we had been told that they were
this is according to an analysis from
the gold standard of evidence-based
reviews wearing Medical
and surgical masks or n95 or P2
respirators so even the fancier kind of
masks to Stave off the transmission of
respiratory viruses may be largely
ineffective
we might be taken off of YouTube for
saying this I don't know we already have
had a strike against the against this
channel we've had plenty of of uh
Medical
disinformation misinformation things
censored out of the show because
YouTube's rules say you're not old but
what am I supposed to do I'm quoting the
gold standard review here I'm quoting a
review from the Cochran Institute which
updated its review from 2020 it examined
78 Global Studies comprising more than a
million people
found that wearing a mask in a community
reduced the risk of getting flu or
covid-like illness
by about five percent
we shut down Society
and then made everybody wear those
stupid uncomfortable disgusting hankies
on airplanes in grocery stores in school
we made these kids wear it in schools it
affected children's development because
you because human beings are mimetic
creatures because we learn and are
educated by mirroring the behavior that
we see in other people when you cover up
someone's face the effect that that has
on all of society but especially young
babies toddlers were just learning a
horrific horrific effect and we did all
of that
to reduce the risk of transmission of
this cough by according to the Cochran
Institute
about five percent
quote irrespective of the limitations of
the study its results indicate that the
true impact
of medical surgical masks and n95 P2
respirators and the transmission of the
viruses is at best very small says
Professor Francois Baloo
professor of computational biology at
University College London
all of which is to say
why do I bring this up to Advocate
against Mass policies while I pretty
much never wore the stupid masks I wore
them under only extreme duress if I had
to take a flight say to go give a speech
and I thought that giving the speech was
worths worth putting on the dumb hanky
to take the flight
but I bring it up now
to give you a little bit of
encouragement maybe a little
chastisement maybe a little
encouragement
I guess it's both
we were right
we were right the whole time about
everything we were right about the
virulence of kovid we were right about
the efficacy of The Masks we were right
about the safety of the vaccines we were
right about the efficacy of the vaccines
we were right about
everything
and some people
understood this very early on pretty
much right when the when the covid
pandemic dropped
some people didn't know that I think
most people kind of know it now but
a lot of people didn't know it for a
very long time and the people who didn't
know it for a very long time were the
people who were willfully trying to
deceive people called a stupid coldest
murderers called us a threat to Public
Health called us uneducated
people in fancy lab coats people on TV
with really straight faces even many
Republicans I'm sorry to say they called
us all those things we were 100 right
so I'm not just spiking the football
doing a little victory dance trying to
bolster everyone's Egos and pride quite
the opposite I'm trying to instill a
little bit of humility in the other side
and I'm trying to encourage people the
next time this happens
the next time
we're told hey if you don't if you don't
put a hanky on your face and jump around
on a pogo stick while singing
zippity-doo-dah you're actually
endangering Public Health all the
scientists say so
and you say ah it doesn't sound quite
right to me I don't actually I don't
think that's true I don't think
trust your gut your gut has a much
better track record your gut is far
wiser and more precise and more prudent
than our current scientific medical
establishment
which is in my view far less credible
than the shamans and the witch doctors
and all the other weirdos throughout the
history of science and medicine
I'm not supposed to talk about that
though okay you know it's crazy society
which is going up and down because the
people really don't know what they're
doing that's why you got to check out
gold you got to check out Birch gold
right now text Knowles to 98 98 98 the
U.S
has blown through its 31.4 trillion
dollar debt ceiling that happened last
month
still the White House refuses to reduce
spending and unfortunately the
opposition party is refusing to reduce
spending now too they won't touch a huge
portion of federal spending 46 of
federal spending they say that's off the
table
if you are worried about the future of
this nation's economy you need to
consider diversifying into gold with
Birch gold Birch gold makes it easy to
convert an IRA or 401K into an IRA in
Precious Metals text nulls Canada View
Las to 98 98 98 to claim your free info
kit on gold and then talk to one of
their precious metals Specialists well
an A plus rating with a Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews you can
trust Birch gold to help protect your
savings text nulls kwles to 98 98 98 to
protect yourself with gold today that is
nulls to 98 98 98 today
we're not supposed to be talking about
the Pfizer expose naughty naughty you're
not supposed we're not supposed to be
talking about all of the errors and lies
and deceit from kovid
our ruling class doesn't want us talking
about that
and and they are going to censor people
who make this a big issue Facebook and
Instagram are moving right now to ban
permanently project Veritas from their
platforms and the reason is the Pfizer
sting video because that was a good one
James O'Keefe he usually brings the heat
I mean he comes with really good stuff
not every project Veritas expose is
created equal some of them have been
less shocking than others
this one's pretty good
the Pfizer exec video is pretty good and
Facebook and Instagram know it that's
why they want to ban James O'Keefe and
project Veritas
even Twitter even Twitter under Elon
a locked project very toss out for about
two hours I assume then they got the
call from Elon I was like what are you
guys doing put project very test back on
but if Elon did not run Twitter project
fairytos almost certainly would still be
off the platform
they don't want us talking about that
and and to me this is a meta-political
lesson
the politics of politics that's worth
paying attention to
whenever there's a big Sensational story
whenever there's a big glittery spy
balloon the first question to ask is not
wow what's going on with that balloon
what are all the details huh let's see
what is CNN saying about the balloon the
first question to ask is
why is this being put in front of me
why is CNN talking about this balloon
why is NBC why is the New York Times why
is Washington Post talking about this
balloon
and what
are we not talking about while we're
talking about that
what it that this is one of these little
Tre it's a little Jedi mind trick of
politics
but at least as important as what are we
all focused on in politics at least as
important as that question is what are
we not focused on
well the magician has his hand doing all
sorts of little showy movements over
here what is that other hand doing
you know what I want to talk about
Well everybody's talking about the
balloon I want to talk about
the upending of our culture I want to
talk about the deliberate
plan by our ruling Elites to blot out an
important swath of American culture and
it's not just me talking about it
Senator Josh Hawley is talking about it
as well
they said inflation was transitory they
said Russia's economy would crumble
under the sanctions of course China did
the big backdoor bailout buying their
oil their AG other countries followed
suit you know we can go on and on with
their failed predictions
have they gotten anything right here
no they haven't Laura but I do I will
tell you this they are getting what they
wanted in an ultimate sense which is
they want to remake our economy Joe
Biden wants to remake our economy such
that we don't have any more blue-collar
work in this country we don't have jobs
for working people all of those folks
have to depend on the government and all
we have instead is this this climate
green economy where you have to have a
fancy degree where you have to get a
white collar job in a big city and if
you want to live in the middle of the
country there are no jobs for you that's
what they want they don't like
blue-collar workers they don't like blue
collar culture and so they're trying to
wipe it out by changing our economy and
Laura they are succeeding we have got to
stop them
Joe Biden wants to remake our economy
such that we don't have any more
blue-collar work in this country we
don't have jobs for working people
all of those folks have to depend on the
government that's his claim and it's
going to be written off by the Liberals
and by the squishes and the liberal
adjacent Republicans as just a bunch of
populist demagoguery here we go here's
Josh Hawley trying to rile up the people
what he's saying is obviously true the
way that we know it's true is that the
elites talk about it openly
they say oh we've got these bitter
clingers out there we've got these
deplorable
irredeemable people they just need to go
away
that's what the libs say and then what
what do the squishes on the right say
they write long articles about how small
town America needs to die
about how it's good that blue-collar
jobs or not even blue collar I guess
just what are called unskilled jobs
are shipped overseas
it's it's funny that that these jobs are
called unskilled because as you see the
Advent of artificial intelligence and
chat gbt you're noticing that the jobs
that are most at risk of being replaced
right now actually are white collar jobs
it's it's actually accountants some
kinds of business people journalists
actually the only people who have at
this moment lost their jobs as a result
of chat GPT our BuzzFeed journalists
whose work is now going to be done by
this computer so there's a kind of irony
to that
but the way that this is working in
practice does not change the plans and
dreams of the ruling class which they
say is get rid of the small town stuff
this blue collar stuff nobody to learn
to code
so they learn to code You Blue Collar
idiots why then you can be like me you
can be living in a tiny little pod
apartment in a major Metropolitan City
with no family writing listicles for
BuzzFeed all day long about how terrible
small town America is that learn to code
idiots
now of course what what is actually
happening
because of the Advent of artificial
technology the new slogan is learn to
weld as as all the journal jobs getting
taken away so actually maybe you should
learn Plumbing learn to plumb huh learn
to weld don't learning to code is not
going to help you very well chatgpt is
going to code a lot better than you can
but but the point
we can we can get a kick out of the the
difference between the the liberal
Elites plans and what's actually
happening in practice
but the plans are important because we
need to know what's our response to it
what's our vision here they have a
political Vision their political vision
is get rid of all the the rube idiot
deplorable irredeemable Americans we
need to get rid of our political
Traditions our local communities our
subsidiarity we need to get rid of a lot
of our national sovereignty ship it all
off to those Geniuses and Davos the
world economic forum and the other
International institutions just give
them all the power let them run our
lives and that way we can all just sit
in pods and eat bugs and all be
androgynous and there are no men and
there are no women there's nothing
ornate or distinctive or beautiful or
traditional about life that's their plan
in a nutshell
so what's our vision
unfortunately in recent decades on the
right
our vision has been pretty much the same
in recent decades on the right because
of a a
very shallow
misunderstanding of what Liberty means
we've pretty much gone along with that
we've said oh yeah
on the gender stuff we say do whatever
you want just don't make me pay for it
that's fine though you can chop off your
body parts or have whatever kind of
weird sex stuff you want to do that's
totally fine no big deal
and on small town America yeah why would
you want to stay in small town America
let's go to Wall Street baby greed is
good let's do it we're all going to be
Gordon Gekko we're going to be Leo
DiCaprio and that Wolf of Wall Street
movie yeah man let's we're gonna be Iron
let's go do it and then
in just in terms of the economy itself
we've been told that creative
destruction is the greatest thing
possible we just need prophets Above All
Else boost up that GDP ship all our jobs
overseas that's fine because GDP might
go up and we'll get cheap junk from
China and then because the junk that
China makes is going to be cheaper than
what we could make here in the United
States then everybody's going to make a
little bit more money as consumers we're
going to be a consumer society that that
just has a little bit more profit margin
for corporations won't that be great
that's what we're conserving there was
always this schizophrenia to Republican
political speeches over the last 20 30
years which is on the one hand they said
we need to defend traditional American
values small town America change begins
at the dinner table also
we need creative destruction do whatever
you want yeah you don't we should loosen
up the marriage laws yeah that's totally
fine we can have divorce we can have
people shouldn't have large families
yeah we can just move to the cities and
ship our jobs overseas and that's a
great thing
what are we conserving
are we only conserving profits there are
many people on the right who if you got
them if you had a couple drinks with
them like the undercover journalist with
Pfizer
they would admit that to you they'd say
yeah that's what we're conserving
they would use they would say a little
more euphemistically they'd say we're
conserving Liberty
but by Liberty they don't mean an
exalted Liberty they don't mean the
Edmund Burke kind of Liberty they don't
mean the founding fathers George
Washington kind of Liberty
that is circumscribed by a a pretty well
defined view of Morality In the way
Society is supposed to work and our
roles in society and gender roles and
social roles and all the rest no they
just mean
go go do whatever you want whenever you
want to do it
what are we concerned we'd just be
conserving leftism at that point
now some conservatives have the right
idea there's this great Congress lady I
have more respect for her by the day
Victoria spartz
she moved to the U.S in 2000
she worked in local Politics the
businesswoman
and then she ran for congress in 2020.
and now she's going to quit Congress
she's not going to quit she just isn't
going to run for re-election so she's
going to fulfill her job her her promise
to her constituents but she said I want
a lot of tough battles for the people
and will work hard to win a few more in
the next two years however being a
working mom is tough and I need to spend
more time with my two high school girls
back home so I won't run for office in
2024. it's been my honor representing
Hoosiers in the Indiana State Senate and
U.S Congress and I appreciate the strong
support on the ground 2024 will mark
seven years of holding elected office
over a decade in Republican politics now
I'm going to go spend time with my girls
because they're in high school now and
we I need they need their mom
yes good yeah now we're talking man oh
now someone's talking
like even slightly almost kind of a
little bit like they want to conserve
something that really matters
this is a great thing yeah she should be
with her daughters
and she has
more of an obligation to be with her
daughters than if she were a man that's
true a lot of people are going to say oh
no come on Victoria you're only giving
in because you're a woman and you feel
like mothers need to bear so much more
of the responsibility of actually
nurturing and raising children into that
and today I say yes that's true
that's true if she were a man she
wouldn't have this kind of pressure to
be at home quite as much
that's just a fact of life
women are more nurturing mothers do have
more of a role in the tactile
minute-by-minute raising of children and
she's acknowledging that and she's
saying I got to do that I got to put
that first that's more important that is
more important thank you thank you to
any Republican acknowledging these basic
realities that that contradict our
modern liberal interchangeable everybody
is the same thing we're all androgynous
kind of
ideology which is obviously wrong good
job she made the right it's I'm sure it
was a tough decision but it was totally
the right decision folks
we've got a timely and important book to
share with you today
New York Times best-selling author
Heather McDonald has teamed up with DW
books to bring you a powerful new book
when race trumps Merit how the pursuit
of equity sacrifices Excellence destroys
Beauty and threatens lives
Heather McDonald is one of the smartest
and and
most correct most on the money political
commentators and Scholars out there
today she's just so extremely impressive
and she always brings the receipts and
her books are always great and this one
is no exception this book is terrific Do
You Believe In fairness and Merit do you
care about the future of our society and
the institutions that shape it this book
is for you in when race trumps Merit
Heather exposes the dangerous
consequences of prioritizing race over
Merit in all aspects of society and I'm
I'm not just talking about this
political area or admissions here or
hiring here because Heather is so deeply
cultured she talks she talks about the
kind of basic aspects of our politics
that she's talking about Opera she's
talking about music she's talking about
law enforcement she's talking about
everything our institutions being eroded
and destroyed in the name of equity hits
the shelves April 18th you can pre-order
your copy today at Amazon or wherever
books are sold
speaking of family values great news
Mark Houck was just found not guilty who
is Mark Howe you might remember him
we've mentioned him on the show here
before he's a pro-life activist and he
was brought up on face act charges
face Act is a terrible law that says
that people have the right to go to
abortion Mills to kill their babies
without having to to deal with
protesters or very often the pro-lifers
outside of abortion factories are are
not even yelling or protesting it's
nothing like BLM or antifa they're
usually standing there praying but the
face act has been weaponized by the
Biden Administration to try to stop the
pro-lifers even from praying you saw
this in the UK there was a video we
covered on this show of a woman silently
praying silently in her own mind praying
across the street from an abortion
Center and she was arrested for it and
we are not that far off from that degree
of tyranny in this country all to to
preserve what Democrats consider to be
the sacred Act of murdering babies so
this guy Mark Houck was brought up on
these charges and uh specifically it was
because he pushed a Planned Parenthood
escort who was threatening his own son
his little son who was there also
praying outside of a Planned Parenthood
so he was found not guilty of course he
should have been found not guilty it was
a terrible miscarriage of justice that
the guy was even brought up on these
charges and while I want to celebrate
and I don't want to bring everybody down
because this is a victory and we should
celebrate it
the doj still got what it wanted here
the Biden Administration still got what
it wanted the pro-abortion fanatic still
got what they wanted
they didn't get everything that they
wanted because this guy's not in an
orange jumpsuit but they got a lot
because
they dragged him through this terrible
legal process they smeared his name and
his reputation
and they sent a warning to other
pro-life activists and don't show up
don't show up outside these clinics it's
going to be a problem for you yeah
you're gonna maybe you won't go to jail
but we're gonna we're gonna make your
life a living hell for months maybe
years
yeah maybe you're going to want to think
twice before you go pray the rosary
outside of Planned Parenthood yeah
and people are going to get that message
the pro-lifers are are so
clear-minded on this issue that I don't
it's very hard to discourage pro-lifers
but there will be some people who will
be discouraged well
it's just gosh I got a lot on my plate
this coming year do I really have time
to go through a potential long legal
battle
I don't know that's the message that's
the message that they want they don't
they didn't need any real law they
didn't need any justice to do it they
could just wield the federal agencies
like the Jack booted thugs that they are
the same people that are kicking down
doors at Mar-A-Lago
invading the home of a former president
those same people being weaponized by a
very corrupt president
not good stuff speaking of crime there's
a video that's gone viral of a little
girl getting beaten up on a bus we've
blurred the face of the victims here
it's a nine-year-old girl being beaten
up by what appears to be a high school
student on a bus
you can see this poor little make out
the size of her body relatively
obviously quite small and the just
absolute animal hummeling is this huge
kid who's obviously much much older it's
just it's heinous that's all I can watch
of it and we still blurred
learn a lot of it
uh horrible scene in a way it's good
that the kids have cell phones now you
wish that any of the people with cell
phones who videotape these crimes would
put the phone down and go help but they
don't do that at least they're
videotaping it so that we can see it
though so what are we going to do about
it
what are we going to do about it the
answer in a in a lot of blue States and
a lot of blue cities which is where a
lot of this stuff is taking place the
answer sadly is nothing
and the reason we're going to do nothing
about it is because
the decision Maker's kids will never
have to go to that school
the people who are responsible
for
a harsher discipline for protecting
students for increasing educational
outcomes they have zero incentive to do
that
that kid who that giant animal who was
Pub pummeling that poor little girl
he got a citation for it
kids should be in juvie I don't know how
old he is I hope he's not 18. he's 18 he
should be imprisoned but if he's
under 18 you should be in juvie for that
that's that is psycho behavior that is
not just kids get into a scrap on the
playground I don't think we need to call
the cops every time a couple of boys get
into a fight on the playground at recess
okay but when a giant hulking animal
teenager starts pummeling some poor
little nine-year-old girl on the school
bus relentlessly pummeling her that kid
needs to go to juvie okay
I don't I don't think that's so extreme
but it won't happen that none of that
stuff will happen
because
the the incentives to to help now are
only if your kids go to that school the
lawmakers kids won't go to that school
and for the purposes of Justice which
which most lawmakers don't seem to care
about these days and our whole culture
mocks the idea of justice and
retribution and a moral order and
tradition so that's at the window and
then what are the disincentives to do
anything the moment that you go in and
try to fix these schools the teacher
unions are going to come after you like
crazy and because these these incidents
are often happening in Democrat areas
the Democrats are totally in the pocket
of the teacher Union
so that's not going to do anything
the moment you get involved especially
if it's a school with a lot of black
students at it you're going to be called
a racist you're going to be any anything
you try to do to reform music schools
you're going to be called a racist
people who try to offer educational
Alternatives like charter schools are
called racist somehow for improving the
educational outcomes of black students
somehow you're still called so and
racist is the worst thing you can be
called in society there's an absolutely
no incentive there
and there's lots of other problems and
hey we got to talk about that stupid
balloon in the sky so no one is going to
pay attention to it it's it's sad I wish
that we could do something but what and
also what are we going to do
when it's it's happening in Liberal
areas
and when even the federal government is
entirely controlled by the libs
just not going to happen other than the
House of Representatives we can call
some hearings it's not
it's not going to matter and it's not
going to matter not just because of
certain bad people in office it's not
going to matter because of the very
structural problems especially when it
comes to education speaking of racial
politics this I I can't I can't leave
before playing this sweet little Lisa
sent this to me yesterday she goes Mac
you you got to see this I said I don't
know I actually already I finished
writing my show the points I want to
talk about tomorrow you know we all have
to talk about that dumb balloon she goes
no Matt you got it you gotta see this
this is a
new Disney show it's actually a a reboot
of an old Disney show which I had never
heard of but it's called The Proud
Family
this is the show
this country was built on slavery which
means slaves built this
till this land from sea to Sea to Sea
first it was rice tobacco sugar cane see
Whitney did his thing foreign
reparations for their suffering and
continue to earn reparations every
moment we spend submerged in the
systemic Prejudice racism and white
supremacy that America was founded with
and still is not a tone Force slaves
built this country not only filled hands
but Carpenters Masons blacksmiths
musicians
and we demand our 40 acres and a mule
you can keep the mule keep the 40.
so at first as I'm watching it I was
waiting for the punch line because it's
so over the top it's this stupid slam
poetry it's making a historical Point
that's just not true obviously slaves
contributed to the building of the
country
but to say that slaves built the country
one is to really overstate the
prevalence of slavery in the United
States compared to everywhere else in
the world compared to everywhere else in
the world especially outside the West
slavery existed in this country for a
very very short period of time and
people were always uncomfortable with it
and it was being phased out from the
from the nation post-revolution's
earliest days
but two it also ignores the significance
of ideas in human nature
in an end in human progress and in
history
because the slaves did a lot of physical
work
not denying that slaves did a lot of
physical labor
but the slaves very rarely did or had
the opportunity to contribute
the ideas that craft the country slaves
didn't write the Constitution slaves
didn't write The Federalist Papers
slaves didn't establish the House of
Burgesses stay slaves didn't do any of
those things I'm not saying it's the
slave's fault the slaves were slaves so
they didn't have much of an opportunity
to do it but obviously
history is propelled in part by physical
actions and labor
and just kind of regular till the fields
kind of Labor then by physical actions
that are inspired by ideas and then by
ideas themselves I mean right the pen is
mightier than the sword
in many ways so the historical idea
Preposterous and then the slam poetry
angle so absurd
such a such a caricature but then I said
okay well you know what it's going to be
it's gonna be at the end of the video
they're going to get done with this
stupid performance and then the audience
is going to be silent like what huh this
is a talent show guys why are you and
what happens no there's a standing
ovation there's no what's the punch line
the punch line is listen to our our
frankly maoist political uh screed and
then you better stand up and applaud too
kids that's what Disney's putting out
that's why DW kids exists that's why
we're doing it that's why Jeremy is
investing a hundred million dollars in
DW kids is and and the other
entertainment content so that
your kids don't I can't I'm I cannot
subscribe to Disney if that is the kind
of crap that my kids are going to see
and then I said what is this cartoon
it's called The Proud Family and I
thought of course it is because all this
stuff always comes back to some deadly
sin and almost always Pride it's the
pride parades it's the it's Sam Smith
giving us Satan performance at the
Grammys we don't have time to get to
that today we'll get to it tomorrow it's
it's the proud family it always comes
back to some sin
it always comes back to some devilish
imagery and that's so anyway that's what
you're getting from Disney if you want
your kids to live miserable lives
cultivate The Vices and probably worship
Satan
subscribe to Disney that's a good idea
if you don't want that
if you don't want them to learn bogus
historical anti-historical nonsense
and you want them to flourish and be
educated and live good virtuous lives
head on over to DW kids it's music
Monday we got some great music today the
rest of the show continues now if you're
not a member become a member
dailywire.com Knowles use code Knowles
at checkout get two months free on all
annual plans
foreign
[Music]